facing a fourth night trapped in their
vehicles and unable to depart for calais
frustration and anger led one group of
drivers
to briefly blockade inbound freight
arriving from france
there was confrontation as the police
tried to clear the road
a demonstrator lay down in front of one
of the lorries
speak to the drivers and time and again
the lack of information
is what's really causing tempers to
flare i don't know what's going on the
police will tell you what's going on
all the ones to move from around the
world let these people come out and bye
bye
good night another four nights here
dover should be bustling now instead it
is
ghostly shut down by the impact of the
new variant of covid in the uk
the french ban on arrivals ended on
wednesday morning
but the condition of travel is
possession of a negative covid test
and getting one of them while trapped in
a queue like this
is impossible testing is available
at the temporary lorry park at manston
airfield which now has nearly 4 000
trucks and their drivers parked on it
the site is on a desolate
windswept hilltop 20 miles away from the
port of dover
the sound being carried on the wind is
the sound of the drivers
inside this airfield blowing their horns
as an expression of frustration and
misery
this airfield is a truly desolate place
to have the prospect of spending
christmas
manston is the government's primary
holding area
it was designed to cope with any
disruption that might have been caused
by
brexit from the accounts of those parked
here now
it is failing its first real test
there are toilets but is it dirty not
working
we have no food we have no water
yesterday the
police organizer organized the food but
it was just a hamburger
some some some chips and that's all and
we don't know
when we can get to home from from that
airport
here too there were confrontations with
police two people detained as
frustration led to scuffles
again the lack of information and
organization
have left the drivers desperate the
government says testing has begun at
manson
but not enough we have two days sitting
here
and then now they say us we don't have
tests
because they're stuck on the way that's
the stuff
yeah yeah the car is still stuck
it's blocked they have one way here
and we don't know the uk government says
it will take
a few days to clear the backlog of
vehicles
christmas for many here is going to be a
deeply miserable experience
paul brennan al jazeera dover